wie legt man am schnellsten und am
sichersten 600 kilometer strecke zurück
mit dem auto mit dem flugzeug
die antwort ist mit dem zug aber nicht
mit irgendeinem gewöhnlichen zug der
kommt ja sowieso immer zu spät sondern
mit dem hyper loop herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge watts orten im jahr
2008 wurde in kalifornien der bau einer
neuen hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke in
auftrag gegeben
die strecke soll die vier grössten
städte kaliforniens mit einer nach
verbinden darunter auch san francisco
und los angeles
das projekt soll geschätzt 42 milliarden
us dollar kosten und bis 2029
vollständig in betrieb genommen werden
doch kurze zeit später kam ihre maske
ins spiel der zukunftsvision er und
gründer von firmen wie tesla motors
spacex oder paypal hat eine bessere
vision für das reisen in der zukunft
nach einiger forschungsarbeit stellte er
in einem whitepaper hyper luke vor hyper
look soll sicherer wesentlich günstiger
viel energie sparen und vor allem
beinahe dreimal so schnell sein wie eben
die geplante hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke
dann nimmt er natürlich den mund
ziemlich voll also wie genau stellt sich
alle macht dem zug der zukunft vor
hyper loop ist im endeffekt eine riesige
röhre auf stützpfeilern innerhalb dieser
röhre herrscht ein extremer unter druck
durch diesen unterdrücken müssen die
züge weniger luft zur seite schieben und
können im wahrsten sinne des wortes
reibungsloser vorankommen
die kleinen waggons mit jeweils 28
passagieren werden dann mit hilfe von
magneten boostern bis an die
schallgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt mit
1220 stundenkilometer
spitzengeschwindigkeit jagen die kapseln
dann von punkt a nach punkt b die
waggons schweben übrigens nicht auf
magnet schienen sondern auf einem
luftpolster im vorderen teil der kapsel
befindet sich ein kompressor der die
luft dann nach unten weiterleitet diese
wird dann unter den waggon gepresst wo
sich dann eine dünne luft schicht bildet
das ganze funktioniert genauso wie beim
eishockey oder bei einem hammer boot
durch den sehr geringen luftwiderstand
hat der hype einen extrem niedrigen
energieverbrauch pro kilometer
und das bisschen energie das benötigt
wird kommen natürlich von solarzellen
die auf dem sagt der röhre
angebracht sind ihnen maske vergleich
seine vision der zukunft natürlich
häufig mit anderen herkömmlichen
transportmitteln während man mit dem
auto knapp sechs stunden für die strecke
an rechnen sollte kann der halbblut
innerhalb von 35 minuten von lr nach san
francisco fahren
in deutschland ist die strecke mit
berlin münchen zu vergleichen
der errechnete preis für eine fahrt
umgerechnet nur 15 euro
die kalkulierten kosten für die hyper
flugstrecke belaufen sich übrigens auf 6
bis 7 5 milliarden us-dollar im
vergleich zu der
hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke die sich
gerade im bau befindet ein schnäppchen
dazu kommt noch dass der hype erlebt
weder entgleisen kann noch von wind oder
wetterabhängig ist aber natürlich ist
nicht jeder von der idee begeistert
kritiker denken das macht kalkulation
von sechs milliarden us dollar
viel zu gering angesetzt wurde und dass
auch er nicht an den ungeheuren kosten
vorbei käme die große infrastruktur
netzwerke nun mal mit sich bringen
anderen wiederum gefällt die idee nicht
über 35 minuten lang ohne fenster auf
engstem raum verbringen zu müssen wie
man auf den skizzen sehen kann gibt es
in den waggons leider nicht sonderlich
viel platz für sportliche aktivitäten
oder eigentlich überhaupt irgendwelche
aktivitäten abgesehen davon filme gucken
zu können
ach so schlimm ist das eigentlich gar
nicht doch ehe max glaubt weiter an
seine idee und er würde sich auch gerne
mehr um hyper luke kümmern wenn er nicht
schon sehr viel mit tesla und spacex
beschäftigt wäre trotzdem wird es beim
sex als firma eine teststrecke bauen
mit ihr soll getestet werden ob die
vision hyper loop auch in die realität
umgesetzt werden kann
außerdem hat 26 vor einer woche einen
wettbewerb angekündigt studenten und
unabhängige teams von ingenieuren sollen
die beste hyper lud kapsel bauen
die pläne für das röhrensystem sind
öffentlich zugänglich und in genau einem
jahr im juni 2016 werden die teams ihre
ipods vorstellen können
die fünfte staffel von game of thrones
ist gerade vorbei wenn ihr euch fragt
wie es weiter geht ihr aber nicht die
bücher lesen wollt dann lasst ihr euch
doch einfach vorlesen bei audible gibt's
alle bücher zu game of thrones und das
allererste dass ihr euch aussucht gibt's
sogar kostenlos
dazu einfach auf die ersten beiden links
und in der video beschreibung klicken
der obere link ist für das allererste
buch wenn ihr also wissen wollen wie das
ganze losging dann den klicken wenn
jetzt gerade mit der fünften staffel
durch seiten ihr wissen wollt wie es
weitergeht dann den zweiten link in der
video beschreibung
ich werde euch nicht spoilern spoiler
für dich scheiße aber ihr könnt mich
gerne spoilern und zwar wie euch das
video gefallen hat daumen nach oben wenn
es euch gefallen hat daumen nach unten
nicht gefallen hat gerne auch
konstruktive kritik und ansonsten wenn
ihr mehr von klicks im netz ansehen
wollt dann gibt es hier die letzten
beiden videos das obere ist eine special
folge zu virtual reality nicht verpassen
und das darunter smartphones der zukunft
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
bis zum nächsten mal